hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 17 video I know
there are a lot of questions about the
big WTF so I'll try to start with that
stuff first before I do top 5 moments
just careful for spoilers in case you
haven't seen the episode yet so the
Suicide Squad rotated its membership
unfortunately Deadshot looks like he's
out until we see his severed head don't
assume that he's dead completely but I
am wondering if they fridge the
character because they're using Deadshot
in the Suicide Squad movie remember this
is the comic book world we have a
Lazarus Pit there's no such thing as
true death not that I think that Lawton
is gonna end up in the lazarus pit and
with respect to Ray Palmer fighting with
team arrow just because they ended the
episode on a positive note with respect
to their relationship I think Oliver and
Ray are still gonna have big
disagreements about how each of them
goes about seeking justice seriously did
anybody count the number of times ray
said the word justice it makes me think
the spin-off show is gonna be just the
society that's a long shot though very
big a long shot okay on a top 5 moments
fun stuff starting with number 5 Diggle
and Lyla get married did anybody else
get flashbacks to the Green Arrow Black
Canary wedding from the comic books that
was so much fun their wedding night kind
of ended in a similar way to what
happened on this show not exactly it
just it all kind of goes to in a
really big WTF way if you haven't read
it you should check out that comic book
it's a lot of fun I think I mentioned it
before but even though Oliver had a lot
of funny moments with the other big
ships that he's had on the screen like
moments with Felicity at the wedding
moments with Laurel at the wedding I
don't think that that character is ever
gonna get married during this show's run
so like if arrow gets 7 seasons he still
won't get married by season 7 they're
just like a couple things that'll
probably never happen on arrow
like for instance Stephen Amell said
that he's probably never gonna get to go
sleeveless if you remember the
Smallville green arrow had like no
sleeves Stephen Amell is like yeah
they're not gonna let me do that even if
we move the show to LA and he's probably
out gonna get married speaking of long
shots though I do think that Batman or
Superman or even both of them will
appear on arrow in some capacity before
it ends its run assuming it gets more
than five seasons on to number four The
Suicide Squad rides again it was a nice
moment in the limo but the big reveal
though is is Cupid joining the team Amy
goo manic you may remember her from
Supernatural but I think it's their time
on arrow now that
one's gonna remember her for I'd expect
now that Deadshot has been cycled out of
the team she's probably going to take
his place so expect her to show up the
next time the Suicide Squad shows up
she's also kind of a pseudo replacement
for Harley Quinn
I think the minute Warner Brothers put a
Suicide Squad movie on the books just
certain top-tier characters a list
characters became off-limits for the TV
show Harley Quinn being the biggest one
there's really no awesome explanation as
to why the TV shows and why the movies
can't do the same characters and just do
their own versions of each mostly I
think Warner Brothers is worried that
the TV show like having them around on
the TV show too much will dilute the
brand thinking of said characters like
Harley Quinn as brands in and of
themselves
I know it sounds stupid and it is stupid
but that's okay it just gives them more
opportunity to focus on the characters
they already have so if you really like
Cupid we will be seeing more Cupid in
the future on to number three hail Hydra
fake arrows kill one to rise in its
place which is funny because I actually
just got done making it agents of shield
video like right before arrow started
tonight we know as the audience that
it's Rashad Ghul who's leading all these
people around to keep referring to it
like it's one imposter like it's one
person I think when they say there's an
impostor they're referring to the person
that is leading all the imposters but if
there was any confusion team arrow
figures it out right away they know
exactly what's going on they're like oh
clearly this is Rachel Ghul trying to
entice me to take his offer I'm always
interested to see which WTF plot points
that the narrative just speeds over the
people just figure out right away and
which things become a big mystery that
have to be solved over a couple episodes
Ray Palmer learning Oliver is the arrow
is another good example of that answer
number two Ray Palmer versus Oliver I
like the way they trap Felicity in the
middle of this without going too crazy
on her both Ray and Oliver just like
super surprised that Felicity has been
keeping such a giant secret from each of
them but what's going on here is they
just they don't want you to think that
Ray Palmer is going to be fighting
Oliver for the rest of the season
yes they will continue to have really
big disagreements about crime fighting
style they just don't want you to think
that they're gonna be working against
each other yes I do think there will be
an atom team-up with team arrow before
he goes off on a spin-off definitely
before the finale team arrow itself is
gonna change quite a bit I don't think
that Ray Palmer
is ever gonna officially be a member of
team arrow I do think he'll be inside
the arrow cave at some point but Marc
Guggenheim explained that his character
is gonna develop apart from the arrow
characters the spin-off I think is the
big reason for that they just want to
show that this character can exist on
his own which is funny because the
spin-off show is gonna be a team-up show
so none of the characters on that show
are gonna be completely by themselves
and a lot of people will be asking about
the way Oliver took down the atom so I
think I think the reason that he was
able to do it so quickly is because the
atom is so inexperienced it's like yes
he has a badass suit but if you remember
Iron Man when he first wore his suit he
was a pretty shitty superhero I think by
the time the spin-off show starts by the
time the pilot picks up he'll be just as
badass as everyone else but until then
his body will continue to be bruised as
he said in the episode I thought was
pretty funny my ego and my body are both
very bruised really that whole fight
scene between arrow and the atom was
just meant to say chill bro we're both
on the same side here
and my number one WTF moment of course
masayo
kills the mayor that's gonna spark a
manhunt for the arrow a lot happened in
that last scene so here's what's going
on Ray Palmer and Laurel will still
continue to think that Oliver's innocent
he's being framed so they know instantly
whoever's masquerading as the arrow
killed the mayor quentin however does
not he still thinks that the arrow has
gone bad so he's gonna lead a task force
to hunt him down
that's what next episodes gonna be about
it's called Public Enemy the arrow
becomes public enemy number one
episode 19 is the one that everyone
should be worried about that's
supposedly the episode when one of the
characters is going to die there's so
many warning signs for so many different
characters right now I'd say the people
at the top of my list are Roy Quentin
and now Diggle and a lot of people were
wondering if Lyla was gonna die because
of what happened with the Suicide Squad
plot I'm kind of glad she didn't but
obviously them trying to quit both the
teams is not gonna go well
interesting that Diggle did not mention
that in his last meeting with Oliver
they toasted Deadshot but they didn't
talk at all about Diggle leaving the
team episode 19 is titled Broken Arrow
that could be when Diggle tries to leave
the team but here's my big question for
you guys how do you want to see the atom
work with team arrow before the end of
the season really what I'd like to see
is like a crowd scene where the atom
uses his arc blaster to take out a bunch
of people while all
handles Rochelle ghoul did anyone notice
how much Oliver's been training with his
sword in each of the last couple of
episodes there's been a scene where
Oliver is practicing with his sword I
think they just want to remind us that
he's going to have a rematch so to speak
with Rochelle goal before the end of the
season and speaking of rematches Laurel
said that she has a new trainer that's
been roughing her up a female trainer
does anyone else think that that might
be Thea I don't know if they're bringing
any new characters on the show that's
just why I say that they haven't
announced any other big comic book
characters they've cast and of all the
females on the show that could help
train Laurel I think Thea is at the top
of the list I think I don't you
mentioned most of the Easter eggs you
know Green Arrow Black Canary wedding
was the biggest one and you know just
because Deadshot is dead on the TV show
right now it doesn't mean he's dead
forever although I do like the hive
shout out like he eat flashes back I'm
actually wondering if Emily Kinney's
character on the flash in episode 18 is
going to be part of hive it just seems
like they're developing the hive
storyline and that's gonna be like a
season four thing I really do feel like
hive is going to be where the big bad
comes from in season four like the place
they originated from so next week
episode 18 Public Enemy be sure to
subscribe to get my video I'm doing a
Q&A for the flash and arrow this week I
know there's tons of questions about
time travel a lot of flash stuff going
on as well as what's going on with the
racial goo League of Assassins storyline
on arrow so be sure to leave all your
questions well you guys wait for that in
case you guys haven't seen it I just
posted my agents of shield video for
this week you can click here to watch
that learn all about like some teases
for Captain America Civil War some seeds
being lame for like shield versus shield
stuff and you can click here for this
week's episode of the flash thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you tomorrow
you